Ця історія На жаль вона про
безвідповідальність от про що вона
ключове насправді в Конституції і в
законах України в тому числі в законі
Про мобілізацію та мобілізаційну
підготовку чітко розписано В кого які
обов'язки дуже чітко і Наприклад щоб ви
розуміли згідно пункту 20 статті 106
Конституції хто приймає рішення про
загальну або часткову мобілізацію так
президент України а стаття четверта
закону про мобілізаційну підготовку і
мобілізацію от я можу навіть зацитувати
вид обсяги порядок і строк проведення
мобілізації визначаються Президентом
України і між іншим а вже стаття 11
цього закону вона чітко розписує
обов'язки
і знов таки це обов'язки президента
України і не просто
так президент України це верховний
головнокомандувач я підкреслюю верховний
і це не просто голос так
знаєте звання чи просто термін це велика
відповідальність і чому він так
називається тому
що Кабмін володіє своєю часткою
інформації і є і має свою зону
відповідальності
Міністерство оборони своєю часткою
інформації і своєю зоною
відповідальності генеральний штаб своєю
розвідка і контррозвідка своєю включно
зі службою зовнішньої розвідки і тільки
одна людина в країні на базі Ради
національної безпеки і оборони А давайте
не забувати хто є керівником Ради
національної безпеки оборони А це
президент України вони цю інформацію
об'єднують і приймають рішення і саме
тому президент України має вносити
будь-які
законопроекти в парламент тому що це
єдина людина яка володіє всім об'ємом
інформації а от те що зараз внесено від
кабіну до парламенту Чесно кажучи ну
слухайте всі ж знають вся країна знає що
це законопроект розроблений Мар'яною
безуглою під диктовку офіса президента
і чесно кажучи він скоріше не про
мобілізацію а про побудову тоталітарного
режиму і
тому між іншим значна частина цього
законопроекту
списана з російських калі копіпаст з
російського закону але давайте не
забувати що Росія - це тоталітарний
режим а Україна - це демократична
держава А чому саме починаючи з того що
забирати права і закінчуючи тим щоб
блокувати рахунки Ну і так далі І так
далі І так далі дивіться коли ми
говоримо
про цю історію я не просто так сказав що
у кожного свої обов'язки і зараз ви
подивіться шокується Влада намагається
все це спихнути на військових слухайте
Залиште військових у спокії не заважайте
їм воювати в них є свої конкретні
обов'язки а далі Коли Вибачте міністр
фінансів каже що я не знаю де знайти
гроші я звертаюся до Генерального штабу
нехай він мені знайде гроші Ну якщо вже
не знаєш Відкрий законодавство і Почитай
обов'язки В кого які особливо під час
війни залужний має визначати звідки
міністр фінансів має взяти гроші як на
мене це ще один доказ
безвідповідальності Коли уряд пана
Зеленського таке озвучує хлопці так ну
взагалі тоді збирайтеся йдіть якщо ви не
знаєте тому що система побудована Таким
чином військові нічого не вимагають вони
вносять свої пропозиції кажуть що
дивіться ось наш задум Ось які ресурси
для цього потрібні це і гроші і зброя і
кількість людей і так далі І після того
Рада національної безпеки і оборони на
чолі з паном Зеленським аналізує все це
аналізує чи є гроші чи є зброя скільки
людей і так далі І так далі і приймає
зважене рішення і на базі цього
президент України дуже зважено вносить
закон про мобілізацію в парламент і
парламент його обговорює затверджу
насправді як ми бачимо
безвідповідальність Одні кажуть не
знаємо де знайти гроші йідіть до
військових інші кажуть мобілізація не до
мене верховний головкомандувач каже що
мобілізація - це не до мене ідіть он до
військових каже військові і верховна а
Верховна рада що може тут в даному
випадку вдіяти слухайте Верховна Рада
приймає законопроект але лі має бути
прийнятий зважений ефективний
законопроект а він може бути прийнятий
тільки тоді коли він базується но
100% правильній вивіреній інформації А я
вже казав що єдиною
людиною яка це може зібрати
це президент України тому що ну дивіться
яке відношення до Кабміну має служба
зовнішньої розвідки а генштаб а розвідка
контрозвідка загальна
і так далі я можу багато прикладів
наводити і
насправді за мобілізацію парламент
голосує і ми голосуємо як ми
проголосували о 8:05 ранку 24
лютого 22го року Так кожні два-три
місяці Зеленський вносить до Ради
питання мобілізації і Рада його
підтримує і ми просуваємося далі Тому
цей закон не про мобілізацію якщо ми вже
говоримо про мобілізацію то ключовий
момент це принципи от позиція
європейської солідарності що це питання
має базуватися на певних принципах і
тоді це вірно перший принцип будь-який
законопроект який стосується мобілізації
Він
має впроваджувати реальне підсилення
обороноздатності цей розроблений
Мар'яною ви бачите що вже наробив він
зробив
навпаки друге будь-який законопроект
який стосується
мобілізації має базуватися на принципі
справедливості один приклад наведу А
чому дбр в нас заброньований і не
підпадає під мобілізацію Що сталося в
них же зброя в них же все сидять купа
дядьок отримують купу мільярдів з
бюджету і не хочуть на фронт трет
будь-який законопроект який стосується
мобілізації не має містити в собі
корупційних ризиків ви подивіться на цей
законопроект
там з десяток корупційних ризиків які
вже закладені і чесно кажучи ну це
страшно його читати з цьго з цієї точки
зору наступний принцип
надважливий не може будь-який
законопроект про
мобілізацію
обмежувати ті конституційні права
громадян які не стосуються військових
дій воєнного стану і так далі ми же
рухаємося в Європейський союз ми
демократична держава А в нас цей
конкретний законопроект просто копіює
російські підходи і насправді
це законопроект Про систему контролю за
кожною людиною в Україні а не про
мобілізацію І наостанок будь-який
законопроект про мобілізацію має бути в
тому числі прорахований таким чином щоб
він не наносив негативу для економіки
Тому що давайте не забувати міжнародні
партнери виділяють Україні кошти
на соціальні потреби пенсіонери вчителі
і так далі і виділяють кошти на зброю
але забезпечення армії зарплати
військовослужбовцям виплати
військовослужбовцям по раненим
інструкторам це за рахунок державного
бюджету і Якщо економіка не витримає і
ляже то де ми візьмемо гроші на ведення
нашої боротьби і це теж треба
прораховувати от саме такі
принципи які ми вважаємо обов'язковими
коли вноситься будь-яке питання щодо
мобілізації от Мені цікаво знову ж таки
оця цифра 500 000 про яку говорив
президент Зеленський і яку підтверджує
міністр фінансів те що він чув від
президента Зеленського залужний цю цифру
не підтверджує він каже ну ми не
подавали таких цифр до уряду звідки це
взялося Це
що от це ще раз говорить про
безвідповідальність але вже з таким
елементом
непрофесійності тому
що ще раз є задум є стратегічний задум
на наступний рік що як нам робити на
полі бою щоб перемогти цей задум
реалізується в цифрах І от якщо ми
підходимо до питання мобілізації то нам
треба чітко
зрозуміти скільки було вже мобілізовано
які втрати поворотні
безповоротні які
перспективи наступного року і Окей я
розумію що це може бути дуже чутлива
інформація але парламент може в
закритому режимі розглянути це питання і
приймати рішення але це якраз ще раз
підкреслюю що жоден кабінет міністрів не
міг вносити цей законопроект тому що
наприклад по втратам На мою думку і те
що я знаю кабінет міністрів цими цифрами
не володіє А як вони можуть вносити
мобілізацію не володіючи цифрами
наприклад по втратам от розумієте дуже
багато але дуже багато але